today we're discussing a truly shocking
chapter and definitely the darkest
chapter of One Piece ever so make sure
to stay tuned for this one if you can
handle it channel the paring within and
smash that like button if you enjoyed
these one piece reviews and want to keep
them coming make this the video you join
the nak if you haven't already by
subscribing and hitting that
notification Bell so you don't miss
future one piece videos and updates by
clicking that subscribe button you're
also helping me reach my insane goal of
2 million subscribers here on YouTube
and I would be eternally grateful for
that and now without further Ado let's
let's jump into It spoilers and all so
we left off last chapter with Jenny
being kidnapped 14 years before the
present it was the biggest Cliff Hanger
ever and finally after a week of
wondering we finally find out what
happened to her exactly chapter 1098 is
called the birth of Bonnie and as the
name suggests Bonnie will play an
important role in this one but also will
find out about the truth of her
backstory and how she's truly related to
Jenny and Kuma so this time Brooke is on
the cover page Brook's pants have an
apology message from Oda saying I
couldn't finish drawing in time sorry
end quote and we're told with the full
summary spoilers that this is a short
chapter of 15 pages and that Oda
couldn't finish the chapter manuscript
this week so many pages are not 100%
complete some panels are only sketches
as far as I know something like that has
never happened if I'm understanding that
right at least for the four years I've
been reviewing one piece so I'm curious
to see how these sketches actually look
and if an actual chapter is really going
to be published with rough sketches and
then potentially be finished for the
volume release very odd won't comment
too much on this until we see the actual
chapter with the official translations
but I'm pretty shocked by this news I
wonder if that means Oda might need even
more breaks in the future but back to
the chapter itself and it's revealed
that Jenny was kidnapped to become a
Celestial dragon's wife we don't see who
is the exact Celestial Dragon in this
chapter but we'll come back to that so A
few things right off the bat first we
know Jenny is beautiful and all the
young men of the sorb Kingdom wanted to
be with her while she was waiting for
Kuma to marry her so it's not surprising
someone would want her for their wife
but so far we usually see Celestial
dragons treating non- Celestial dragons
or commoners as slaves who are beneath
them rather than as potential wives so
I'm curious to find out the specifics of
this situation why would the Celestial
Dragon consider having for lack of a
better term a commoner as a wife that in
itself caught me off guard and since Oda
hid the identity of the Celestial Dragon
this chapter I assume it will be an
important reveal when it happens happens
and I assume we may find out more about
Jenny's past before she met Kuma and
before she became a slave when we find
out about who this Celestial Dragon is
and why he's so fixated on her
specifically I doubt the Celestial
Dragon in question will be figar land
Garling but he's definitely the main
Celestial Dragon on people's minds right
now because of his recent reveal and
focus in the manga let me know if you
got any theories for which Celestial
Dragon this could be or if you think
it's an unnamed one as of yet it's
reported that Jenny's en entire
revolutionary Army troop was annihilated
in a surprise attack by the world
government which kind of makes me think
this has to be a big player even among
the celestial dragons I mean think about
it Charlos got punched in the face by
Luffy and still the world government
haven't caught and punished Luffy even
though he wasn't always as strong as he
is now yet one dude says he wants jinny
and the world government wipes out her
entire revolutionary Army troop and
kidnaps her just like that I doubt every
Celestial Dragon has that kind of sway
so I think this dude will be a big deal
even among the celestial dragons keep in
mind we were told this kidnapping
happened 14 years before the present day
last chapter after Jenny was kidnapped
the Revolutionary Army became more
violent and Kuma specifically became
much more intense in battles again
pretty crazy for the world government to
do this and ignite an enemy like this
just over one women for one Celestial
Dragon unless that Celestial Dragon is
important but back tokuma and yes No
More Mr Nice Guy The Gentle Giant
finally snapped and no one can blame him
after all he's been through he's been
through so much already and
unfortunately it's going to get even
worse for him in this chapter as we'll
get into poor poor Kuma we see the
moment when the Revolutionary Army
picked up people from Goa Kingdom after
that Kuma teleported to another Island
to help the rebels Kuma ended the battle
on that island all by himself that's how
much of a beast he became after losing
jinny I can't wait to see that
single-handed Crush Illustrated then
we're told The Tragic Truth About Bonnie
she is the child that was born from
jinny and the Celestial Dragon that
kidnapped her now this is YouTube and I
can't say what the implication is here
but it's pretty obvious and definitely
helps make this one of the darkest
chapters of One Piece yet and as if to
let us know that it wasn't like Game of
Thrones a rhaegar Targaryen and lyanna
Stark situation it's revealed that two
years later AKA 12 years before the
present events of the story Jenny
contracted a mortal disease disase
called Sapphire scale even rarer a
disease than Amber lead syndrome the one
law suffered from with this specific
disease when patients came in contact
with natural light sunlight or even
Moonlight Sapphire scale caused their
entire bodies to become blue and their
skin gets harder like rocks or scales
Jenny became unrecognizable due to the
disease so the Celestial Dragon released
her we're told we can't see jinny's face
in the chapter but can just hear her
voice jinny then returned to sorbet
Kingdom and left Bonnie with the elders
from the island so a lot to unpack there
not least of which is that Bonnie is
like 12 years old and this is something
I was right about when I said there's no
way Oda would have said her estimated
age was 24 if she was actually 24 Oda
going out of his way to say estimated
rather than stating it outright in the
SPs made it clear that it would be
something else and although a lot of
people brushed it aside when vega Punk
said Bonnie was just a little girl
saying it was because he was old old or
whatever it turns out that it was as I
expected at the time Bonnie is actually
a lot younger than expected and to boot
she's at least half Celestial Dragon and
I say half just because again we don't
know about Jenny's past before Kuma and
before she became a slave at four so I
can't comment 100% on what race Jenny is
or social status although it would
definitely be weird I admit that she
would go from being a Celestial Dragon
to a Slave at four so most likely Bonnie
is just half Celestial Dragon now the
reason this suggests that it's not like
a rhaegar and lyanna's Stark situation
from Game of Thrones is because it was
assumed in that world that rhaegar did
the Unspeakable but then it was actually
revealed that they were actually in love
and married where here even ignoring her
hots for Kuma Jenny wouldn't have ended
up being released because of her disease
from the Celestial Dragon if it was love
her disease wouldn't have been a reason
to boot her out and her child so it
really seems like it was a Celestial
Dragon who kidnapped her because of her
looks and marriage her and when she got
sick and unattractive no longer wanted
her so Oda getting very dark indeed it
must be said though there are stuff that
I'm still confused about like why was
she released instead of being kept a
prisoner in some isolated jail or killed
considering how cruel the celestial
dragons can be and why if the Celestial
Dragon was motivated by lust would he
want to marry Jenny why go to the point
of making her his official wife we
haven't really gotten satisfying answers
yet for these questions whatever reason
though Bonnie is the legitimate child of
a Celestial Dragon from the looks of it
so that may well come into play in the
future and honestly this makes me want
Bonnie to join the crew even more
because we know the crew is a mishmash
of all kinds of different people and
adding a Celestial Dragon who fights
against Celestial dragons along with the
crew would be very cool we have so many
reasons to hate Celestial dragons and
Oda made sure of that but then he also
gives us Shanks and Bonnie two
characters we love but who are both at
least part Celestial dragons as well so
you with the most hated group in one
piece of celestial dragons would have
wants to make it clear that your
circumstances at Birth do not have to
determine your fate and who you become
but back to the chapter and after Jenny
leaves Bonnie she calls the
Revolutionary Army from inside the
church where she lived with Kuma she
says I really want to see everyone again
but this is farewell Ivanov says what
and Kuma says what are you talking about
Jenny I thought I'd never see you again
where are you right now I'll go
immediately during their conversation
they identified Jenny's location so Kuma
teleported to sorb Kingdom Jenny said
one last thing to Kuma but he couldn't
hear it because he was teleporting where
Jenny is and what did she say nothing
less than the following Kuma I love you
end quote man this chapter really makes
the heart weep these two had a more
tragic starcross love than Romeo and
Juliet 100% Kuma arrives to sorb Kingdom
but jinny is already dead first say mom
then his dad and now Jenny too the woman
he loved and only never got with because
he didn't want to endanger her life in
the life of their potential kids because
of his Buccaneer blood he didn't want
what happened to his parents to happen
to her and yet she ended up dead just
the same heartbreaking stuff Kuma lays
Jenny to rest and her name Jenny with a
G appears on the grave Kuma decides to
raise Bonnie even though now we know
she's not his biological daughter and he
gets help from the elders as well but he
plays a big role Kuma teleports to help
the Revolutionary Army from time to time
and we can see montages of Kuma's
activities with them including him
training Sabo a cool touch but on a side
no interesting that we have cases like
Dragon who never saw Luffy to the point
Luffy didn't even know he had a dad and
then we have characters like Kuma who go
out of their way to raise a child who is
not biologically his however it must be
said she is the child of Jenny the woman
he loved more than anything so it's not
surprising he would want to take care of
her so ended up being a father to her
and didn't have to worry about his
Buccaneer blood making her a Target but
unfortunately if the world government
wasn't going to kill her it seemed the
sapphire scale disease would Bonnie
develops it too and clearly sooner than
jinny did man this is so sad at this
point that it's reminding me of clad
after Story those who know no Kuma
decided to quit the Revolutionary Army
and take care of Bonnie fulltime and
again you can't help but wonder why
Dragon yaso don't even decide to see
their kid sometimes but in Dragon's
defense at least he does allow Kuma to
do it and he even tells Kuma that he
will ask all the doctors he knows in
case any of them can help Bonnie Kuma
has no idea what to do to treat Bonnie
so he decides she can't leave the church
this way she would avoid natural light
and so she should be okay right it's bad
enough she can't go outside but at least
she won't die right just wait for the
answer to that Kuma brings Bonnie books
about different Islands to read he
spends time with her and asks her
questions like if you could travel
anywhere where would you go Kuma and
Bonnie enjoy spending time together as
father and daughter they even dance as
we've seen in flashbacks before Bonnie
had the blue stones on her face because
of the sapphire scale disease and that's
why Kuma called her jewelry now isn't
that just the sweetest explanation to
her pirate named Julie Bonnie you would
have thought it's cuz she loves treasure
or money like a normal pirate but no it
was because of her caring father who
looked at what others might call
repulsive scales and saw his beautiful
treasure of a daughter the highs and
lows definitely make Kuma's backstories
one of the most impactful hands down
there is no story more tragic and yet at
the same time there are so many moments
of beauty and love like this one all I
can say is Bravo to Oda this story is a
masterpiece definitely one of the best
which is saying a lot after 1,100
chapters of good backstories some years
pass and we are now 6 years from the
present and Bonnie is 5 years old so
she's not even 12 12 but 11 in the
present so yes Blackbeard is looking
like more of a villain than ever and on
an unrelated note it's very impressive
that Bonnie was able to get a bounty of
320 million berries at the age of 11
crazy let that sink in and by the way
Roger had kid Shanks on his crew so I
think again Bonnie would make a great
addition to the straw hats and would
love to see her be the final straw hat
let me know if you agree or if you think
it should be someone else anyways at 5
years old Bonnie's disease was getting
worse despite the fact that she wasn't
going out these guys just can't catch a
break why do you do this to usoda why
Kuma talks with the doctor about
Bonnie's disease and the doctor says
that although Bonnie never came in
contact with natural light the disease
will continue to get worse with age and
she will die at around 10 years old
Bonnie overhears the conversation but
only the around 10 part she is very
happy since she misunderstood the
situation she thinks she will be cured
when she turns 10 after all Kuma always
told her optim mystically that her
disease will be cured one day and now he
can't bring himself to tell her the
truth and he doesn't know what to do one
more year passes Bonnie is six and we
are 5 Years From the present the chapter
ends when that horrible former sorb King
from the last chapter returns to the
sorb kingdom and starts to kill sorb
citizens what do people do ask for
Kuma's help yet again man Kuma you don't
deserve all this tragedy I just hope Oda
gives him a happy ending at least by
giving Bonnie a happy ending if nothing
else now my guess is Vega Punk is a key
player here when talking about the Cure
perhaps Kuma pushes out Bonnie's illness
with his ability takes it into himself
and since he's going to die anyways
allows Vega Punk to do the whole cyborg
thing now hopefully the floating
memories we saw before will be able to
return to cyborg Kuma and he will become
his old self again no longer affected by
the illness but man this has got to be
one of the darkest chapters and yet
still had such beautiful Shining Moments
as well this is going to make everyone
cry when animated I mean if anything
will this backstory will and then we're
told there's a break next week but let
me know your thoughts on this chapter in
the comments do you also think that it's
one of the best just from a storytelling
perspective and if you want to know more
about why not all Celestial dragons are
the worst I know it's hard to believe
but if you want to know why they're not
all the worst check out my hourlong
video about SA figar land Shanks link on
screen right now like And subscribe to
help me reach my insane goal of 2
million subscribers here on YouTube and
I'll see you in the next one